could Scott Bakula return to Star Trek
maybe welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV a movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
so during a live streaming fundraised an
event called track talks 2 Scott Bakula
made a rare interview appearance now he
doesn't do this very often in particular
talking about Star Trek but that's what
he was doing and he was talking about
his disappointment at Star Trek
Enterprise ending after the fourth
season he was talking about how there
were lots of problems with the network
it was UPN back then the network channel
that eventually became the CW and there
was lots of changes big changes going on
at Paramount they lost a lot of
Champions on the boardroom for Star Trek
during that period And he says actually
if things had been a little bit more
settled from a business point of view
they'd have gone on to do seven seasons
and no bother he actually says the
numbers we were getting for the show
were Way Beyond what anybody expected
the show was successful it was doing
well and that was not why it ended up
getting canceled now I would question
that I've seen a lot of ratings static
Enterprise was the lowest rated out of
the Four Star Trek shows that aired at
that period it was lower than DS9 lows
the Voyager and way lower than TNG so I
do question the numbers thing but Star
Trek Enterprise for me was actually kind
of slightly ahead of its time you
actually look at the overarching stories
that they do for Enterprise and
particularly the zindy conflict that's
how Star Trek is now that's how lots of
streaming series are now that actually
TV shows like strange new worlds with
the monster of the week style where it's
a different story each week there might
be a storyline interwoven in there but
an actual different stories we is
actually quite unusual most streaming
series now particularly like 10 12
episodes tend to have one storyline like
Enterprise did all those years ago now
I've actually talked about Enterprise
quite a few times here on Sidetrack
please don't forget to like And
subscribe and hit the Bell notification
if you are new to a channel I've
actually argued in the past that Star
Trek Enterprise failed not in the
production value of the show
it was a beautifully made show not even
in a lot of the stories they try to tell
but because of the basic failure for
them to actually explain how the
Federation became the Federation
I always loved the relationship between
the humans and the Vulcans and
Enterprise particularly in the first
season that they were like an
overbearing parent not letting the
training lead off not letting us get out
there and start exploring that they were
afraid of what we might do or who we
might come across I've always thought
that that was really really clever
because it completely makes sense the
very logical Vulcans and the maybe
foolhardy humans and how that
relationship would work I can completely
see that it would be a rocky quite
difficult relationship for me
Enterprise's failure was that they
didn't concentrate on what we wanted we
wanted the origin story of the
Federation what we got was a temporal
Cold War
that nobody asked for nobody cared about
and really to be honest just confused
everything it allowed them to sort of
play with Canon a little bit because
you're saying well there's time
travelers so you know we're allowed to
change the way things go now because you
know timey whiny stuff now I find that
irritating I find it quite lazy and as
you know it just annoys me
but it did let us see the Enterprise J
now the Enterprise J is the stupidest
looking Starship I've ever seen
but it's still kind of cool too that we
got to see it thanks to the temporal
Cold War
um the whole Nazis thing where the
temple Cold War sort of come to an end
in those two episodes it was stupid
beyond belief but you know
Nazi aliens
oh you can't really argue with that
either to be honest even though it was
ridiculous it still actually really
worked but anyway
so that was the problem Enterprise
genuinely had really interesting
characters I really liked the ship I'd
have loved to have seen a fifth season
with the refit of the Enterprise
you know with the drive section here
from underneath I think I think actually
that looks stunning that model it
actually looks like a federation
Starship and I would have loved that
Evolution I would have gone nuts if
they'd done that and started season five
but Scott Bakula also talked about maybe
returning to Star Trek now how could he
the character Jonathan Archer is
mentioned throughout many of the seasons
of Star Trek he was one of the
pioneering captains of the early
Federation he was seriously important
supposedly in actually the formation of
the Federation not that we ever got to
see it but anyway Michael McMahon in the
past has talked about how he would love
characters from Enterprise to appear in
lower decks he's just not sure how to do
it it would obviously have to be a time
you windy episode because there's a long
time between Enterprise and um TNG where
roughly
um the lower deck series is based so it
would have to be a time in Miami episode
but some of the best Star Trek episodes
are those time travel episodes when they
returned to the original
um Enterprise I think DS9 didn't avoid
you did it but the DS9 episode was the
best one the trouble were troubles that
was just a great episode so lower decks
could completely do that and it looks
like Scott Bakula would be very
interested in May be doing a voice he
even mentioned that he would love to be
a Legacy character and how much he loves
it being called a Legacy character
instead of you know like the old Star
Trek people so it seems to me that maybe
he has already had that conversation at
very least he's thought about it
but are there other characters from
Enterprise that could return to say
something like strange new worlds well
the Vulcans do live a long time you know
they can live 150 160 170 years old that
would allow characters like tapal to
appear in strange new worlds as an older
version of her original character she
would still be possibly alive now I
would absolutely love to see that I
liked the tabol character I'd love to
see where to Paul is now and I actually
think that could be an episode of
strange new worlds I wouldn't mind
seeing unfortunately there are very few
other characters like Jonathan Archer
would have to be like 140 but we've
actually seen that before does anybody
remember DeForest Kelly appearing in
Star Trek the Next Generation
well he did if that subject troubles
here troubles me
so damn Troublesome about not having
died
how old you think I am anyway 137 years
Admiral according to Starfleet records
there have been rumors about Scott
Bakula returning to Star Trek for a long
time to be honest and maybe we could see
episodes that would fix some of the
problems of Star Trek Enterprise and
maybe we could see some of the
irritations of Star Trek Enterprise
getting resolved like for example really
seeing how the Federation became the
Federation that would be nice
but do I think it'll happen
I'm just 100 certain he'll do a voice
for lower decks I actually think that's
probably already in the plan I think
they're going to do it
um I would be surprised if they did
anything with strange new worlds and if
they did it would be something like to
Paul appearing in an episode again
easy to do and would actually be pretty
cool will we see the nx1701 again though
probably not but guys get into the
comments and tell me what you think
about Scott Bakula and Jonathan Archer
may be returning to Star Trek is that
something you want to see also if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification so
you miss none of our new videos and if
you really enjoy the content and want to
support us even further consider hitting
the join button as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]